it may not be home but migrants looking
to settle in the United States have a
new place to lay their head in New York
City officials opened this tent facility
Wednesday to process an influx of Asylum
Seekers on a small island not far from
Manhattan
here they can get a meal and a shower as
well as medical assistance you will not
see this anywhere else in the country
and I hope that the takeaway here from
all of you is that New York City is
doing everything possible to make sure
Asylum Seekers are treated well with
dignity and that their well-being is
first and foremost in our mind
but it's meant to be a temporary shelter
for men only as the city's homeless
shelters are at capacity these tents
will hold up to a thousand people since
April nearly 20 000 migrants have come
to New York bussed by Governors from
Southern border states in protest of
federal immigration policies New York
officials have described it as a
political stunt but clearly it's also
been a logistical nightmare
the buses have been arriving with no
warning or coordination on average five
per day at first catching the city off
guard leaving volunteers to pick up much
of the slack like Izzy thielman and her
group team TLC she's critical of the
city's response
building a tent city on a beach or on
Randall's Island is not the solution
there are empty buildings in this city
there are hotels there are housing
buildings that are are abandoned or
empty earlier plans to put the tents in
another location were scrapped after
objections from Neighbors migrants most
of whom arrive with nothing say they
appreciate any help they can get
we have to go out and really beg on the
streets which really isn't advisable
but we have to because in the residence
where we are staying it's basically just
bread
there really isn't any food
so it's all difficult with clothing
everything
but yes there are organizations offering
support organizations
with more of them arriving every day the
city is looking for more places to House
women and families as well as assistance
from the federal government Kristen
salumi Al Jazeera New York